all right hello everybody hello hello
hello hello hello
can everybody still hear me coming back
up we are coming back up we are coming
back up hello hello hello hello hello
hello hi hi hi everybody hi hello
everybody thanks for stopping by and
sticking with me
we are going to be hitting it hard very
very very soon just gonna give a little
bit of time for everybody to weed in
here and then we'll be good we will be
very very good mmm num num num num num
num them ah hello hello hello are we are
back up and are next and these a custom
story is the anguish mmm I got snack
just tell me power through this last bit
to some potato chips um mmm mmm mmm so
good hmm oh I can't Dan oh good they are
mmm now no one except the mods can post
links I'm sorry it's just a safety
measure to keep everyone you know
balanced and in check if you want if you
really want a mod to post a link for you
you got to send them a message but there
might be uh it might be difficult to get
that in time if it's something that's
urgent mmm all right so the anguish the
anguish is our next one
I don't think I ever will stop making
videos especially for lovely fans like
yourself the custom story that I'm doing
now is called the anguish there's
actually a higher reviewed casting story
than the other one so I have high
expectations for it mm-hmm
alright the anguish by Kitty fin the
years 1856 you are rich doctor who lives
a wonderful life you have a beautiful
wife a big mansion money and a loyal
Butler but then one night when you
arrived home from your friends where you
have drank wine with him you notice that
something is wrong
dun dun dun start me um-hmm
Justine would make a pretty wife I
suppose you're not bad to look at wah
all the night and wine was perfect
I'm a bit drunk I should read those
faster I suppose well my hand my hand is
like permis duck no I just can't open
that one ok nevermind I'm ok alright ooh
dinner boxes good thing I'm a smart
doctor and keep all these tinderboxes on
hand hmm hmm yeah I'm a doctor this time
I'm not derma covington I'm a doctor and
I will be respected as such oh you're
hungry are you oh so good mmm I love me
some tater chips hmm hmm okay I don't
ever I don't have a lantern yet my name
is dr. herp mcdr Pinton very different
than my cousin derp Mik her Benton ah
notes I was missing notes I like reading
notes mostly just cuz I like to read
uh-huh what kind of crazy kid am i I
actually like to read I'm crazy as that
boom or tinderboxes oh here we go oh
there's a female voice hi honey I went
to see my sister I will come home at 11
o clock see you then and hey I left the
key to the hallway door on the table at
the left side of the window
hmm oh no no no no one like that no oh
sorry sorry sorry I just trying to be a
little you know that's my so duckie
that's my seductive women leave voice
right right right
always my sanity solo I'm not exactly
sure
haha sorry
hahaha that was my best voice ever
really that one yeah I'd agree with you
I should talk like that all the time oh
okay no uh whose plot is that honey are
you alright
I'm fine dear haha what the hell okay I
like how the music just stop for a
second
Oh No whose blood is this
a week ago when I was in the food cellar
updating our food supplies I suddenly
hear something fallen hit the ground I
went to look at what it was and found a
jar in the floor as soon as I touched it
a loud and scary growling echoed through
the whole cellar level I didn't stay to
check the source of it so better not to
tell the doctor about it what why why
wouldn't you need why would you not tell
the doctor about a loud scary growl I am
a doctor I can handle loud scary growls
it's a part of my medical training I'm a
professional at least I have full oil
that's awfully nice all right then
hmm
hahaha what that man is you just got
restored why some something someone said
in the comments reminded me of Colin
Mochrie and whose lines in a way is like
I'm a doctor
of course it what best was the one where
they were doing the helicopter skip or
they had to airlift up passengers bit by
a snake out Ryan and Colin moving people
it was great sir I hit the west wing key
to the fireplace just like your wife
asked when you come home I'll be in the
cellar checking off food supplies for
this weekend doing some cleaning the
West Wing key to the fireplace the key
to the fireplace oh say what was when
key in the fireplace that makes much
more sense all right a cellar key my
Butler must have mixed up a West Wing in
the cellar key I should go see him and
change the keys he'd probably dead
Holmes okay that's not ice not the
cellar I have to find the cellar
yes of course the butler is going to
kill me
makes so much sense ah the cellar
Bob had leave but I'm here for you
ladies all of you ladies I'm a rich
doctor I own a mansion
are you ladies impressed yet you chest
I'm a doctor I like to hide things in my
own house that on I know I'll need later
oh yes I know ladies I know
your bot whoa okay something changed the
music definitely changed I don't
recognize that music anywhere what kind
of doctor keeps his house in this kind
of disarray and what's with these chairs
who's he doing feeding people down here
really kind of creepy down here but he's
locked cabinets oh oh oh I wasn't even
looking at that one Oh God ah ah man
oh man ooh boy
alright then alright yeah that didn't
that didn't scare me but that was good
that was good that was terrifying but
that was really good I'm more impressed
that they did that than anything I'm
impressed
I'm like really impressed that that just
happened that was awesome that was
awesome whose terrifying but that was
awesome oh man ha ha ha yes here's how a
more impressive anything what hey get
nah stay open now
oh man I'm gonna get jumps gram I spit
their drips everywhere all right
another jump scare maybe boxes no jump
scare okay
yeah or I'm gonna choke choke and die I
think is another option see what's that
key got it food storage key something
behind here obviously what have we got
find a way to move that shelf hmm very
interesting
yeah sorry if there's lag it's on your
end I'm rendering the video just fine
and uploading it at a pretty low bitrate
so so if there's lag it's unfortunately
on your end or twitch you can blame
twitch - so anything else over here I
don't think so the lag is oh so sexy
hmm
the most delicious tempting tantalizing
oh I think I just move that shelf hmm
yes I am so strong and so smart
what the hell what if those lights come
from well how do I get this open this
doesn't help me key no can't use dirt
that way that doesn't help me at all
okay I got to find like a tool a saw or
hammer crowbar something just anything
that can rip those off the wall another
thing I saw another door or something
but there aren't tools here maybe there
was something I was supposed to grab I
don't know hmm now nothing under there
uh-huh
I can rip something off you oh don't
tempt me darling okay enough of that
enough of that yeah I got it I got to
remember that people are gonna be
watching this afterwards so they'll have
no idea what's happening let's see huh
I'm actually confused okay I pulled that
switch but you know there were the
board's there I don't know what I was
supposed to do maybe I threw something
at them let me try something at it that
usually helps
Oh Oh No yeah Oh what do I do
I don't have any tools of any sort oh
wait no of course I got to go find the
food storage area obviously okay so let
me go find a food storage area I bet
there's a crowbar or something in that
area
yes how did that not work hmm okay I'm
actually gonna avoid talking into the
mic directly too much oh right here of
course I'm an idiot
ping click ah lovely oh this is my house
really I kept it in this kind of
disarray Oh terrible me cuz I know
there's gonna be jump scares and I don't
want to be shouting directly into the
mic cuz that would be but oh oh I think
that's my Butler why is he naked
why was my Butler naked down here I'll
ride this warning with my last breath I
was cleaning the north part of the
cellar when I heard the same disgusting
growling again which I heard in the last
week there is something in the cellar I
managed to lock the door to the food
supplies room with that something had
already sunk in its claws in me and my
key gets stuck in its nails I have been
hiding here for about five hours and
I've almost bleed it out if someone
happened somebody happens to see this
note I have a dagger in my cabinet which
in my room at the West Wing
ketta the cabinet is the rest of the
text is covered in blood all right so
anyway huh there's a monster coming good
thing I got these see any potions I have
a doctor after all all right I heard a
doctor or I heard a monster I didn't
hear a doctor I heard a monster all
right um no no sort of a hammer just
standing up there that's weird clang
hidin still no tools I need to find it
oh no II no of course I just got a
crowbar I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot
don't do whatever again
don't do what
this game could have a voice over me I'm
so witty and clever I am a doctor after
all ha ha
dr. herb mcdr ping Tintin thank you what
does wait a minute wait a minute I don't
remember this part of my house oh I have
a feeling that I should ride come on get
out of the way Oh God
Oh Maggie good Gigot good oh you're
gonna lose this key to key to the west
wing oh man ha ha ha oh my god
gay to the west wing oh man
I saw it coming but I didn't see it
coming out of the maiden thing the Iron
Maiden
oh all right I thought I'm supposed to
hide the Iron Man or something uh okay
wait am I going the right way
yeah I'm going the wrong way yeah I'm
going the wrong way oh man freaking I
was a grunt not a moose man Oh hmm wavy
it's a wavy
okay now to the west wing of course oh
boy Oh lovely ah thank you that was it
what that was the end what that was
short that was exceptionally short I was
hoping that was gonna be longer mmm
man I hate I hate that people just
release these really short part ones or
prolongs or something like that yeah I'm
gonna play another I'm gonna play
another I'm actually gonna play another
right now I'm not even gonna bother
cutting out I'm gonna play another don't
you worry ladies I'm gonna be here for
you
I love playing these games for you and
entertaining all of you here I'm just
glad that you could stop by yes
absolutely
hmm
all right thank you anything here how
about um yeah that's one I've had my eye
on for a while I know it's one I'm gonna
play me I'm going to play me me by Zoran
Jay you wake up in a room
clueless how you got there you notice
that you drank an amnesia potion but why
you ask yourself where am I what is this
place
how did I get here it's time to get some
answers star ding ding dong ding okay I
just had to silly it up a little bit
mmm what the hell okay
can't see anything
oh there we go oh all right then
okay
why did I take that amnesia potion I'm
just this is gonna be the last custom
story I play so after this one it's the
end what is it there something oh that's
just the wall on the other side after
this one I'll be done and I'll let you
guys know what special super special
secret thing we're gonna be doing for
next week's charity livestream no not
last custom story ever of course not one
second I'll get to that note look out
for these symbols on the wall they can
be any color they mean that there are
probably a few extra supplies hidden
some when you buy in this case on top of
the bed okey-dokey ooh hello
kliklak so I got to look out for these
symbols on the walls huh oh hello good
notices to the lobby
hmm someone told me to stop being
awesome so all right I got too much swag
for being awesome anyway Yolo let's get
this [ __ ] started where the [ __ ] at
Oh God got so much swag I [ __ ] love
Justin Bieber God is the best there ever
was Oh God
I'm just so great let me talk about my
dick I really like talking about my dick
hmm Oh God hmm all right Bob Justin
Bieber's new album I'm gonna see him
next week wait in town mm-hmm the paper
is quite all blah blah blah Oh what is
this [ __ ] it's boring
ha ha ha Oh what No oh sorry I wish I
had a hat I could do hipster Marc and
then I could do scumbag Marc huh okay
enough of that back to awesome mode yeah
all right mmm mmm mmm mmm I know I know
I know I know guys oh wow
hello it's a little house out there
Luna's bedroom who the hell is Luna do I
have a family that I forgot about the
library
these things are awfully close together
for being there
well there's my lantern huh sorry sorry
I might have yelled into the mic there I
got to stop leaning in seductive mark
has to go away for a bit cuz it's time
for a scary game mode mark where I yell
a lot
horrible my dear friend Joseph sent me
to this house asking me for a
professional help about something
extraordinary but all I encountered is a
haunted house full of dead bodies cools
in deform zombies some of them disappear
when you get close to them but don't
test your luck I am most likely trapped
here forever
so whoever finds this note I wish him
good luck okay
delivery Rory hmm back to the lobby
that's not very much of a library okay
the main holes lock do there must have
been a key in there behind a book yeah
there must have been a key behind a book
or something yeah okay go back in
or switch well maybe maybe whose library
has pulley books maybe just maybe huh no
I don't see anything I don't see those
symbols I don't see anything
hmm just ink what's going on oh there it
is
ah duh click there we go
I knew this was gonna slide somehow got
it bedroom key all right going to Lunas
bedroom ah
Luna's bedroom I'm gone I know habeeboo
woo hoo known her own harem I was joked
I guess there was the demonic cool the
professional was writing about re was
gonna be a boo ver bad time to eat a
chip I swear nah man I go all over there
got chip fragments everywhere ha ha ha
oh poor mark killed by potatoes
the disgusting fat-ass known as
markiplier was eating stuffing his face
with a but I don't have ah we go you go
booth your booth haha never enough of
her that was not a buffer that was not a
buffer
wow man hmm hmm oh yeah good thing I'm
so skilled ah ma'am
okay here we go Oh down up down down
down up I'm gonna write this down oh I'm
gonna write this down on the back of
someone's name musica who's gonna be the
lucky winner today oh it is Christopher
cuts congratulations you're gonna have
this written on the back of your note
down up down down down up then down up
down up
congratulations Christopher cuts
congratulations you're not the best but
you're alright you're up there you're
pretty far up there congratulations
all right so I got that there
okay so I got the code oh wait no yeah
wait why did I write that down I've got
the frickin note right here I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot I was thinking SCP okay
that's locked where I didn't keep the
notes I'm an idiot but I'm I'm an
adorable idiot right ladies right ladies
yeah yes I am okay anyway back to
seriousness what has it ever been
serious I don't know
forbidden section this is my house why
is there forbid oh no I know it's not I
don't know where I am that's right I
thought I was I thought I was the doctor
again for everyone everyone who's
watching I'm still the doctor just for
practicalities purposes outside can't go
outside I'm still the doctor hmm yes
this is just like me working on my
patients ah doors hang on I gotta go
back I didn't want to go into storage
because I saw a desk there and I know
there's something but I probably need in
there I don't want to be in here anyway
dr. herb Mik derping t'en I am NOT gonna
be associate going to be associated with
that laughs talk of a cousin of mine huh
I am dr. hurt Macduff Anton there's a
section of the mansion that no man can
explain the corridors change if you
touch something frightening monsters in
your worst nightmares come to life and a
few people just out of the curiosity
entered this section and never came back
we have closed this area in Hidden
Mickey in the Alec we call this the
forbidden section where no man should
ever go but women are fine women can go
in there running back to this storage I
try ladies and gentlemen hmm
this looks suspicious who knocked over
this chair hmm I like this one it makes
up for all the notes I didn't get to
read in the last one
several the servants have been reporting
that whenever they go to some specific
rooms of random object appears these
objects have been examined and it has
been concluded that they are torture
equipment all of the currently spawned
tortured objects are placed in a
separate room to avoid any injuries the
room is locked in the key blahblahblah
the looser hard read and you notice is a
clear line made as if someone was pulled
back while holding the pen down oh so
that's what happened
that makes sense click link no keys I
don't have any keys rub rub a radical
Larry no not radical Larry locked again
lots of locked rooms around here oh the
symbols is there items near by under the
stairs there's actually something under
the stairs I can't believe it there's a
birthday of my life I'd like to thank my
parents I'd like to thank my cat I don't
have a cat but I'd like to thank it
anyway
oh this best here my life oh what's all
this hmm for those of you don't get it
I've been looking under the stairs in
almost every single custom story and um
like 90 times out of 91 there's nothing
ah stop that I wasn't even that scary
okay dead guy why dead guy paintings why
paintings all right so
what am I looking at here nothing
seriously nothing there's nothing in
here gotta be something in here now just
a dead guy and some paintings some books
Cole nothing huh okay nah those guys
please okay all right good okay we're
okay I didn't get anything I don't know
why I went down here why did I go down
here why did I come down here why did I
go down here what was the point what was
the point of all this I've already been
here there's nothing here I've checked
this area I don't know what it wants
from me maybe there was something down
in that room I'm thinking they might
have been
we had to be I mean there was there's no
other way to progress I suppose maybe
there is I'm sure I'll just double check
and then I'll come back okay nothing
underneath anything clickable this dead
guy doesn't have anything in his hands
nothing
aha I I knew it I knew it I freaking
knew it I knew there had to be something
okay got it
get out of my way please thank you all
right thank you I got it I got it I got
it I got it can't use it on that one
I got it guys I got it I'm just I got it
I got it I don't like mannequins I got
it I got it
there's blood dripping from that one
okay here we go Greg cram yeah lock what
up Oh what the hell
uh-oh this is the room with all the
torture equipment that mysteriously
appeared so far 15 deaths and 39
injuries occurred during the strange
spawns of this torture equipment one of
the cases indicate certain Iron Maiden
magically opened itself just to grab the
target and close itself again strange
blood falling out of this room ceiling
is rumored to be the mentioned victim's
blood oh that's lovely my favorite huh
please don't grab me
Iron Maiden's mysterious key to a
mysterious door Bank leg leg leg leg
lately nothing I think in this brazen
bull nope huh
okay carrying on okay yes lots of blood
they will be blood mysterious key to the
mysterious door nope not that door
apparently maybe the door downstairs hmm
yeah how does a prize you know almost
every single custom story I played and I
haven't played that many there's
photographs but they never use the
photographs aha well this is a
mysterious room that spawns equipment
maybe all they just put they put these
desks here and they know that I have to
go through them all I have to it's like
an obligation find nothing in them
anyway
nothing in them but I just got to go
through them all because I'm asinine and
slightly OCD like that what if there is
something what if there's something cool
all right fine never mind
oh here we go let's see ours that code
say hey you down are you up down down
darn Oh
bling blong bang bang blam blam blam
bling Barrow bling down bling Oh what up
well what what what maybe there are more
up Downers nope no no more the statues
are still just standing there
I don't like it I like it what oil do I
have plenty actually surprisingly large
amount of oil I actually do not have a
key you're actually wrong in that regard
aha
I knew it oh this looks bad
hello baby are you gonna scare me
well I guess it's okay if you scare me
I'm okay with that darlin
you brought your friends if you think
you're gonna make me jealous
that's just not the case darling you
only only go for me and I'm only only
guy for you okay never mind I'm getting
out of here
oh hello slightly dead guy no you're
still alive uh why why what was the
point of coming in here anyway is there
um a reason I'm gonna leave now
there might be a key yeah I know
oh there it is this right there rusty
key ahaha no no no no no no oh god I
felt safe for a second and then I to go
for Lu uh okay uh okay okay they're not
gonna give me they're not gonna give me
while I hit up my soda I have my tater
chips
I didn't read what that said sorry I'm
not a pooper is it but not a pooper Oh F
expert skill on the door closing yeah
right good job for me alright come on
come on come on huh man huh yes Dr
Pepper ten I hate the commercials left
the soda actually does taste good the
whole it's not for women things like the
stupidest angle Oh still there okay you
want it you want some you want something
oh what oh what Oh what
boink yeah that's what I thought yeah
miss me okay why don't we have a stack
of boxes here what's the point what's
the point what's the point what's the
point why are these here
fires easier are these here okay over
the point close the point close aborted
coming in here there had to be a point
there had to be a point there had to be
a point there had to be a point there's
not a point is here there's no point
there's no point there's no point no
point there's no point where you go what
done what what oh yeah oh i pwned him
out of existence oh yeah that's right on
the best some under here
why were these boxes be here anyway
there had to be something oh wait new
this ah
come on get out of the way boxes I got
stuff to do Oh Road wrong okay there we
go keep all crap I gotta I got boxes
many boxes many mini boxes here coming
through coming through ah ah run ahead
run the face Oh such epic pwnage you go
super fast why did I go super fast no no
no how did it go Superman no I don't
know
hey no I don't have anymore laudanum I
am actually out of laudanum I mean man
holy crap
oh man hmm hmm okay alright alright take
a little break mmm-hmm
alright let's go mmm all right now
that's my favorite music
the frickin prison oh hello supply
somewhere nearby I don't want to use
beds probably anything no oh there we go
finally God I needed this
real bad there we go much better
but I bet I'm just gonna hurt myself
again real soon so it don't even matter
like some of these man they're been
really stingy on supplies in this
playthrough or this game look really
stingy okay they're all locked oh it's
really freakin dark in here it's really
freakin dark in here I'm gonna run out
of oil on it probably probably
bellboy nope why are all of these locked
okay obviously need to get something to
break that padlock and then I'll be okay
let's see Oh someone else is doing a
36-hour marathon that's insane
all horror Wow that's crazy
good for them no here we go
got a key here and uh high-level
security prisoners such as these need to
be released for breaks and lunch times
one by one the order is as follows bla
bla bla bla bla bla okay if those are
codes I'm gonna remember them for later
nope nothing there oh come on come on oh
come on that's not even funny that's not
even funny
ah did you move oh you didn't move
that's just a new one oh okay so I
didn't get any on yes I did since this
is a prison it could take forever to
find the right door or or or or what not
that one definitely or or or what okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] oh boy not that nope oh
boy oh boy
nope okay lovely is gonna be fun or okay
ah there we go got it thank you thank
you thank you thank you
maybe not Thank You Becky ah oh why did
I pick the one custom story with frickin
mannequins oh I hate just darkness
all right Osama oh no another this one
is a bit rusty er than the last why do I
need to find these keys okay not that
one no one was already open no boy there
was something behind the trashcan
no there wasn't liar liar okay not that
one
bitte rustier than the last stop there
we go
see it's easy now Oh moving like
clockwork ten Oh chip er I can use this
oh and a key I see you rusty key oh boy
dot dot dot yeah oh oh the codes oh
you're right
oh you're right the codes oh well I mean
okay I don't know wait hang on the codes
you're right you're right you're right
when you're right you're right
Oh coach okay so the next one in line
gdv azr okay gee oh this one didn't even
have a number I don't know where that
one is huh
all right anyway er KS this one doesn't
have a number oh man ok not that way
wait a minute that was it right that's
all of them
this must be it oh I must be on number 4
I don't know oh ok hello
your boss speaking there has been a
slight error in the key making process
one of the keys does not open the WKCE
cell instead due to mistake it opens
another empty cell I asked you to look
into this problem good luck that's not a
good problem so what cell does this one
maybe the unmarked cell the left here
probably yep ok I heard that
that's moves man is that moose man that
was moose man wasn't that's boobs man
has boobs man
oh there's nothing over there there's
nothing over there ok I just gotta hide
you cuz this is obviously a hiding place
and I'm the one object gonna I'm gonna
hide here no you want my chips you can't
have them
ah okay all right date your friend
Ashley I've dated a couple Ashley's
there all right I'm neither
I bet she's adorable but I didn't find a
key in here why was I in here
I am find a key what am I looking for in
here huh he's coming oh he's come I
didn't find anything in here oh shut up
move man all the door wasn't he oh that
was close oh whoops mm ha ha I choked on
a jump ah okay
is he going away seriously where the
frança fracas is freaking key in here
it's supposed to be a key in here
correct I mean that's not just you know
it's not just [ __ ] around that's
that's actually real there supposed to
be a real legitimate key in here he's
knocking down doors for me
oh maybe he knocked on a door where he
came in that might be possible okay I
already been in there
let's under the boxes under the box is
always a possibility I should be
throwing them in the place that I am
before I start wandering off just be
thorough it's always a good practice all
right
nope by the looks of it it is not under
the boxes okay throw in the trash can
nope okay um we're out of here okay so
this one is still locked and I don't
have a key
hmm for the why the hell cuz there was
got to be one in there right there's got
to be something in here I might just be
losing my mind but I'm I'm almost
certain that there has to be one in here
somewhere
right and I mean I gotta be right I'm
right right right I'm right right right
I'm wrong or not I'm so wrong I'm wrong
about everything everything I've ever
done I'm so wrong yeah I'll try the
chipper on this but I get the feeling
that I need a hammer too yeah I need a
hammer as well wasn't there Bucky I
already checked the bucket there's
nothing in the bucket man I really
thought there would be something in here
I mean I'm not just going crazy right
I'm probably gone crazy
I mean there's this immovable box check
the doorframe yeah I guess since that
other game there was one like that yeah
but nope by the looks of it that's a
negative yeah it's just I've checked
every inch of this room and maybe the
mooch man has a key please honor hey
Sean say that
huh really weird yeah I don't know I
don't know about that I don't know
it's smoky it's weird I don't know the
first room then out said it was empty
which note said it was empty I don't
think it said it was empty
how many other custom stories I played a
few probably probably this would make
like 10 or 11 I don't know I guess I
could check these oh boy oh there no no
dammit I don't know
I'm gonna run myself out of oil here
just looking for stuff oh yeah that's
right oh you're right
oh let's see so man I'm confused what do
I do
I can go back into the main let moose me
into a locked door how long have I been
playing this one only about I don't 2025
minutes
no you didn't it's still locked yeah
it's still locked
what up hi what was that who be banging
who's banging huh huh huh yeah I thought
no nothing in here damn it
nope see it's still locked I bet there's
a hammer in their mamas yeah don't worry
about the view count people come and go
all the time
it's pretty standard yeah
oh I just don't know I don't know oh no
no hmm
well I guess by the looks of it just
nothing in here I'm gonna try going I'm
just gonna try going outside into the
main hole there maybe there's something
else in there
yeah the ambiance in this area is pretty
creepy that music is not fun times yeah
there weren't any carpet zone there were
no carpets and there were no hmm there
are paintings here nope uh-huh
hmm all these doors are locked
I know that I've tried him before see
let's see here okay it huh yeah it has
to be in the prison room somewhere so if
anybody if anybody has seen someone play
or play this himself if anybody wants to
give me a tip I don't want us just stay
stuck here forever so if anybody knows
when I'm supposed to do please say it
now and I'm looking at chat this is
called me this custom story is called me
see that doors still locked that's the
door that I need to get try the chipper
on the lock door that'd be smart no can
use that that way oh wait a minute
no okay yeah that's still locked there's
two locked doors have I tried turning it
off and turning back on again hmm this
is good idea yeah there might be I dunno
I see loud down a dumb teleporting naked
guys Cincinnati Ohio is watching is I
mean I'm watching myself hmm weird
mmm
Milford Ohio oh that's suspiciously
close yeah this cell is just empty check
on top of the closets probably a good
idea
try the chipper on the box hey you know
I'm open to ideas like that whatever
could happen yeah
no object to use it on nope ah okay
yeah I've scoured every square inch of
this place looks like that's a no-go
unless it's like under way tucked under
this or something I don't know nope
mm-hmm okay check where the tree is
again oh okay I'll try that room again
yeah I remember the doors
giving this from a throw look see loo no
no no no no no let's see here
here's a tip use the chipper on
everything is that an actual tip or do
you actually know what I'm supposed to
do because I'd really like to get
explicit instructions as to what I'm
supposed to do here like not in the mind
of cheating but in the mind of keeping
everything moving yeah I live in
Cincinnati Ohio well that's why I'm
asking people to look it up yeah I'm
actually asking if people can go look it
up hmm the storyline is you have amnesia
okay I'm checking the top of cabinets I
check the top of cabinets other in other
rooms now this one didn't have one let's
see locked
on top of this cabinet no on top of this
cabinet no see you super look for a
breakable wall ah that might be a clue
there's a note okay all right
look for a breakable wall underneath the
rock next to the tree hmm check under
all the beds I've already checked under
all the beds okay no breakable wall in
here I'm actually gonna run out of oil
like immediately soon breakable wall in
the room without a key
that's um no see is that some no nope
ah don't look like some no definitely
not in here let's see this custom story
is called me just am the e there's a
sign in the wall symbol in the last room
this room which one I'm confused
let's see here
symbol on the wall
yeah I know you guys aren't helping at
all so okay while people are looking it
up use a chipper and on the lantern now
I don't think that would help
what lantern anyway okay um the room
with the beds in the closets okay I'll
go in there but uh in the meantime while
people are trying to help me out on this
one
let's see beds in the closet this one ah
looking around I don't see anything as a
note on top of cell G DVR this chains on
the wall yeah I know there's change on
the wall let's see the wall is broken
and I'm out of oil now don't look like
it hahaha let's see find the hammer
under a bed let's see alright I'm just
gonna I'm gonna look it up myself cuz
you guys aren't any help you ever gotta
know how to look up stuff I'm story me
dant dun dun oh look at this oh well it
looks like a playthrough mmm let me go
look it up now skip ahead
alright in the meantime I'm gonna let
you guys know what I'm doing in terms of
um in next just because some people want
to go to sleep
um some people want to go sleep so I'll
let them go to sleep and that means
let's see next week on the on the custom
ah on the livestream that we got going
on next week I Bob and Wade they're
coming over to my house we're gonna have
a little land party we're all gonna be
in the same room live streaming at the
same time that's what we're gonna be
doing let's see let's see now let's see
you know so I hope you guys like that
yeah we're gonna have a LAN party we're
all gonna have it hopefully I'm gonna be
able to set it up so that we can all
have um we can all have our own webcams
on our own faces so I hope you like that
let's see so there is a broken wall
somewhere is what your guys are saying
so just scream out when I'm in the
correct room just yell your heads off
when I'm in the correct room am I in the
correct room
no I don't think I am can't even see the
game okay whatever I'm gonna look it up
again
alright I'm looking it up screw you guys
I'm looking it up I'm looking it up
doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo doodly-doo a little
don't oh dear editing yes so while I'm
here what is this hey no God so while
I'm here I will just entice you all with
the sultry sounds of my voice I know you
only see my face because I'm not
actually playing the game now yes oh yes
man does no one have a full playthrough
this game yeah I know the cell next to W
okay alright fine I'll take your advice
fine fine fine then fell next to W K see
the cell next W K see this one it has a
breakable wall this one this is this is
the correct one this is the correct cell
yes this is the correct one
immediately left from wkc oh you mean
this this one that's locked you mean
this one that is locked cuz that one
that one this one this one
hi I'm gonna I'm gonna look up it again
okay
sorry folks gonna look it up again let's
see who is the guy who is a guy that had
it I need to see it myself what was his
name who's the guy that had of the
playthrough Nath plays that's it okay
don don don hold on do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do
let's see y'all and there we go that's
more like it
finally okay just bear with me for a
little bit longer and I will have this
for you mm interesting
hmm quite quite interesting now is that
the correct video okay good
dun dun da da da do-do-do-do-do do-do i
observing very carefully
one second still holding on
still watching very closely mm-hmm
yeah yeah I'll get this in a second yes
ah yeah please see okay almost there got
that got there got there is there stick
the boxes up like that and then there's
nothing there and then the monster walks
in and then the guy goes running around
away from the Moose man and then other
things happen and then he busts out he
goes down that way that door is locked
that door is busted open oh you gotta be
kidding me I know what's wrong I know
what's wrong guys
I'd actually know what's wrong my game
is bugged my game is legitimately bugged
my game is legitimately bugged because
this door is supposed to be busted off
its frame that's what's wrong if you try
to say that you didn't say very well oh
that's correct my game is bugged I can't
get through this quite literally the
game has ended for me and I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try to reloj to save earlier
for when the moose man comes out cuz if
I can get in there I might be able to
still solve that that would have saved
me a bunch of time fighting on that long
long time ago so let's try this autosave
here man that would have saved me a lot
of time
okay where I'm on damn nmi over here I
read the note already okay let me try
the other save just to see where that
puts it you knew the whole time but you
didn't tell me how could you how could
you how could you off how could you all
do that to me how could you do that to
me
yep all that searching well it confirms
one thing at least I'm not stupid okay
so I'm back here so if this is here this
is early this is good enough
ah so this is still here I'm using this
alright here we go
speed run Oh like a boughs I'm so fast
I'm eating tater chips here we go I got
it I'm all over this oh let's see
oh there's a note blah blah blah blah
then okey oh no no no nothing behind
there oh yeah all right
yeah I go through here and wait what why
didn't that statue up here wait a minute
wait a minute why didn't that statue
here okay that's weird
okay this one works okay I'll find this
I'll find this so good I can't remember
which order it goes in and I'm not even
bothering to look at the names mmm
no I'm just kind of concerned because
things are changing wait a minute what
that what wait what boy
oh yeah it's someone over here I'm an
idiot mmm this one I got it no no what
the hell I just use it on all of them
well happy birthday whoever's birthday
it is what that what wait what what what
what what what what put it I tried I
like what what huh read the note I read
the note let's see but now I've tried
all of the doors kvv that's this what
I'm looking for is Q that's K V V this
is a last custom story I do it just
happens to be taking him a lot longer
than I was thinking it was gonna be er X
wait what that wait a minute what am i
doing where the hell is Celeste let's
kvv why am I being stupid what is going
wrong with my brain bye bye thanks for
stopping by tiara er KS yeah until this
story is over that's when I'll be done w
k qy
what what the hell
wait a minute that can't be right
yeah that that can't be right at all
the hell is going on I swear that I was
able to find this I swear that I was
able to find this much easier before
I've tried almost every I've tried every
door in here and I know it doesn't go to
these Wow wait what that can't be right
I'm so confused right now ah I'm like
I'm altum Italy extraordinarily confused
cuz this worked before I'm wondering if
like something bugged out because of the
fact that the statue didn't appear and
now things are just in a loop
Abraha what start from square one okay
all right I'm just gonna try every
single door again no I am so utterly
confused right now
cannot users item this way let's see can
I use this item this way can I use this
item this way [ __ ]
oh man this is so weird
this is unbelievably weird maybe like
what that can't be right that is
actually that is what the hell is going
on with this custom story that cannot be
right I mean for one v the thing with
thee o man that know what all right [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] alright
this is the last time I'm gonna try to
redo this because something is [ __ ]
up and I don't understand why okay so
I'm in the prison I got this first thing
here right here and I know there's
nothing else in this room I know that I
know that for a fact there's nothing
else in that room
yeah I'm really hoping this custom story
works guys sorry about this I want this
to be a bit more entertaining but
supposedly this is supposed to work
correctly and I don't even see a que
vivir see all right well that is kvv
that is the key to que vivir so that key
is supposed to work with other stuff
okay now when I open there's some toys
to go ah Google ghost and then I like
that or something that we this
high-level security britain or such as
II need to be released for breaks and
lunch times one by one the order is as
it follows so kbv is already open so qy2
should have been next and nope he's not
there
so technically qy2 is supposed to be the
next one absolutely with utmost
certainty qi2 is supposed to be the next
one
qy2 is supposed to be the next one but I
cannot use this item in this way all
right well I'm sorry guys I'm really
sorry
I'll try leaving the map and entering
again that might do it
try that one last thing if that doesn't
work then unfortunately I I can't finish
this custom story it just bugged out
completely I don't know why I mean two
separate bugs in the same area is kind
of disturbing hmm all right I'm back in
now no dinner box left qy2
nope can't use this item this way yep
yeah sorry about that guys that's just
gonna be the long and the short of it
nope I'm not gonna play a new one it's
too late to start another one anyway
I've been live streaming for three hours
now so I'm pretty much done for the day
unless I can magically somehow get this
to work again I don't think it's gonna
happen so I am gonna be done for the day
yep yep nothing yeah I just it just
bugged out yeah the script bugged nope
I'm done for the night thank you all for
stopping by
yep yeah yeah yeah I know I know I know
I know I know I know it's unfortunate I
hate to end it on this kind of note but
that's the way it is sometimes sometimes
the custom stories aren't stable but
that's the first time I've encountered
one that actually completely stops me
from progressing so it would fun while
it lasted so thank you all so much for
watching and just as a goodbye mmm
just as a goodbye present to you lovely
people out there here's your favorite
song
that's a tortoise
dude that's a tortoise it's still a
tortoise in water a tortoise lives on
land a turtles not a tortoise it's not
hard to understand
that's a tortoise okay alright so that
is the end of the livestream thank you
all so much for stopping by I'm glad I
could entertain you for as long as I
could I pride myself in my longevity
stamina whatever you want to call it
okay so in case you didn't know and
you're just stopping by my name is
markiplier I run the YouTube channel
markiplier game you can click on the
YouTube button in the description below
to go to my channel there's also a
Twitter and a Facebook you can like me
there and follow me on Twitter and
listen of guilt is linked to bust of
stuff by me and if you read the FAQ
that'll probably answer all of your
questions so thank you all so much for
stopping by oh and one more thing I also
sell t-shirts if you were at all
interested in Bose they have a really
cool design here's the link here I
should put this link in the description
but there's my Spreadshirt that's where
I am and if you check it out here you
can see this awesome t-shirt for a frame
of reference this is a medium like so
this is a medium and if it's really
nicely too well mates turn so you can
find them take it off now not today lady
not today ladies so anyway thank you all
so much for watching yeah walking dead
in 52 minutes go watch that arm
Dexter coming up tonight as well so
either way tons of stuff thank you so
much for watching I really enjoyed this
it was a lot of fun I wish that could
have ended that livestream but that's
just the way it is so thanks again
everybody and I will see you in the next
video bye
Hey bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye